hello and welcome to the recent stream
I'm Zach Weissmuller joined by my
co-host Liz Wolfe and today we're going
to react to some clips from the second
GOP Presidential debates which took
place last night at the Ronald Reagan
Presidential Library and museum in
California a fact that we were reminded
of regularly with constant invocations
of Reagan's name and Legacy and here to
help us make sense of what to make of
the state of the GOP going into the 2024
election is Josh Barrow a journalist and
commentator Who currently co-hosts these
serious trouble podcast with Ken white
and writes the very serious newsletter
published on substack Josh thank you for
joining us hi Zach thanks for having me
yeah before we get into the clips uh
that all of us have chosen I want to ask
both of you you know all of us here none
of us here are loyal committed GOP
voters uh
we're also I I don't think any of us are
loyal committed uh Democrat voters so
Independence looking at this at this
latest debate what did the overall tone
and substance make you feel about the
current state of the GOP and let's start
with Josh
well so first of all I I am a Democrat
often somewhat reluctantly I also used
to be Republican quite reluctantly I
think that political parties are
important vehicles for influence in the
country and it makes sense to be a
member of One even if they drive you
crazy all the time
um but you know the thing that I found
remarkable about this debate is how just
completely detached from reality it was
like the obviously the front runner's
not there
um and to the extent that the people on
this stage are running for president and
that extent varies from like low to no
they are running against Donald Trump
and yet the debate was structured like
it that they were running against each
other and it's like an argument over
whether Nikki Haley or Tim Scott is the
better choice to be the Republican
Presidential nominee and that's just
that's not a question anybody's asking
that's not the question before anybody
and so a lot of it just felt very
theoretical in in a way that some of the
2020 Democratic debates felt where it
was like you know arguing over exactly
which flavor of single-payer we're going
to implement if we win this election and
have a majority of four in the House
Representatives
um but but even more theoretical than
that because at least you know that it
was you could close your eyes and
imagine the idea that you'd have some
election that resulted in Elizabeth
Warren being elected president or
something like that whereas here you
know like I spend no time thinking about
the possibility that Tim Scott is going
to be president of the United States 18
months from now so it just it kind of
felt like a useless exercise in certain
ways would it feel more useful if there
was a narrower group of candidates on
the stage at this point and maybe but
the main thing is they need to talk
about Donald Trump more and I don't mean
that they need to talk about Donald
Trump more in the sense of like they
just need to talk about how awful he is
and especially I don't mean they need to
talk about how awful he is in the in the
same way that you would if you were a
Democrat running in a general election
but they need to be making the case like
why should you nominate me instead of
trump because that is the only relevant
question before Republican voters right
now if they if they're going to vote for
one of these people it has to they have
to have decided that they're not going
to vote for Trump and you have to make
that case and there were glimpses of
this and you see there are ways to do
this without running at him from the
left and you saw Ron DeSantis making
pieces of this argument and saying you
know we need a two-term president
picking specific pieces of his record on
debt and that sort of thing and
criticizing them for basically not being
conservative enough uh but it really
that's like that's the only important
argument for these candidates to be
making is you know why why me instead of
him and it just felt like only a very
small fraction of the debate was
actually focused on that
hmm what was your reaction Liz I am sort
of stunned by how they don't know how to
take the W I keep thinking about this uh
in relation to the DeSantis candidacy uh
and the DeSantis campaign and it's like
well wait a second you have in my view a
pretty excellent unimpeachably good
record to lean on with covid policy in
the State of Florida with executive
experience uh I believe he won the first
uh the first time to be the governor uh
by a pretty slim margin but the second
time much more handily uh a lot of the
people who live there perhaps you
included Zach are very happy with his
record so I'm kind of stunned by how a
lot of these Republicans don't know how
to convert that legitimate leadership
experience some really good executive
experience into something that actually
appeals to voters I mean even when
questions on inflation or dangled before
the Slate of the candidates they don't
seem to know how to actually connect
with people I'm sorry but this should be
be a relatively easy pitch the Donald
Trump question which I think you're
totally right about Josh that's a lot
harder to figure out how they got to
position themselves in relation to him
and I think we've seen a lot of miscepts
so far but with a whole bunch of like
issues that affect the lives and
pocketbooks of everyday Americans this
should be a pretty easy thing I mean I
think the young kin Playbook is actually
kind of an interesting thing to look for
um you know basically when you have your
opponent uh this was in Virginia the
gubernatorial race when you have your
opponent saying things along the lines
of like oh well parents didn't really
have control over what kids are taught
in the classrooms a bunch of parents
respond really negatively to that
regardless of partisanship and I'm kind
of surprised that kovid record inflation
uh issues related to just absolutely
horrible performance of public schools
and the influence of teachers unions
which I think a lot of leftists have
sort of become a little bit more aware
of and a little more pissed off by
lately uh all of these things could be
winning issues and for whatever reason a
lot of these candidates don't seem to
know how to convert their beliefs or
their positions or their experience into
something that's actually a really
compelling pitch to voters
yeah I mean uh speaking as someone
coming to you from DeSantis land yes I I
generally am pretty happy with how
things are done here in Florida the the
governance
um I've got some bones to pick on
various approaches to trying to shape
the school curriculums and so forth but
on kind of the big picture things it's
unfortunate though that as you say it's
presented in this kind of wrapper and
and I have to be mindful of the fact
that I am not the audience for this uh
Republican primary so it's it's going to
be in that culture War wrapper it's
going to be buried beneath you know
calls uh to put troops on the Mexican
border which we'll get to soon
um and then you know to to Josh's point
you know I I think
that it has been a real problem that uh
the the the orange elephant in the room
is just never seems to be addressed uh
head on and and maybe uh if the field
gets winnowed down that that'll change
but let's uh pivot into some of the
clips that we've pulled to react to
um the the first one uh that's that Josh
said he wanted to talk about was uh
DeSantis seemingly calling for military
and intervention in Mexico let's roll
that and talk about it
commander-in-chief I'm going to use the
U.S military to go after the Mexican
drug cartels they are killing our people
and the stories that I've seen in
Florida we had an infant 18 months
parents rented an Airbnb and apparently
the people that had read it before were
using drugs the infant was crawling the
toddler was crawling on the carpet and
ingested a fentanyl residue and died
are we just going to sit here and let
this happen this Carnage happen in our
country I am not going to do that so I
guarantee you on day one this border is
going to be a day one issue for me as
president we're going to declare it a
National Emergency yes we'll build the
wall we'll do remain in Mexico but those
Mexican drug cartels are going to be
treated like the foreign terrorist
organizations
so is that a threat to invade Mexico
yeah like is it a declaration of war on
day one right like what's the legal
mechanism here yeah I mean I I think war
and Terror you can you can imagine a
situation and and Mike Pence has had
sort of more reality-based things to say
about this you could imagine a situation
where you have some sort of cooperation
with the Mexican Government that
involves deploying U.S military assets
in Mexico with their permission and
maybe you could even pressure them in
certain ways into doing that but I I
don't I don't think it's at all clear
that you necessarily would succeed at
that amlo is you know is very much a
nationalist and I think is unlikely to
be keen on the idea of the U.S military
attacking cartels in inside Mexico and
if you do that without the Mexican
government's permission you have invaded
Mexico it's like it's it's this really
it's this really hawkish bizarre idea
that could have all sorts of negative
unintended effects and it's just sort of
being thrown out there like it's a thing
like oh just like send the military
um and also like you can't you can't
you'd have to send troops if you wanted
to do this sort of thing I mean you
can't because I mean part of the problem
with the fentanyl trade is because
fentanyl is physically so small the
quantity of it that you need and because
it's synthesized
artificially you can't just like
identify sites from the sky and drop
chemicals on them or bomb them or that
sort of thing if you were truly to have
an effective operation like this you
would have to have a U.S military
presence in Mexico which would be a huge
policy change and if they're really
threatening to do that without the
without Mexico's permission that's
literally a threat to invade which just
seems crazy
and the more moderate Nikki Haley
positions just spend send Special
Operations there so it would be sort of
I guess like off the books uh CIA
operation or something like that I mean
the the underlying issues here are that
uh we've got immigr we've got our
immigration problems and then the drug
war and from my perspective the the
inflow of fentanyl into the country has
been a direct result of uh drug
prohibition uh Fentanyl
has exist existed as a uh medication and
an
anesthetic uh in hospitals but the
reason that it's spilled onto the
streets is because we went from an
opioid epidemic to a heroin problem to
now a fentanyl problem and I think that
the approach that you know that that the
discussion around decriminalization harm
reduction is of course completely off
the table for the GOP but there's also
the question of immigration which is uh
you know brought up uh uh over and over
again
um on on that stage and
for the amount of times that Ronald
Reagan was invoked there was not a
discussion of the fact that the Reagan
Republicans were a much more welcoming
party I mean Reagan at the time you know
offered an amnesty and also basically
was talking about a you know a highway
connecting Canada Mexico and uh and the
U.S like we're all you know we're going
to have a new North American Alliance um
so that is obviously in far in the rear
view now but
it's it it's got to be part of the
solution any serious solution to any of
these problems is uh actually
allow figuring out a way to meet the
demand of the people who want to come
and live and work here peacefully Liz
completely I I think uh there's also an
interesting component of this which is
very difficult to argue against because
I think it effectively tugs at people's
heartstrings but like the anecdote that
DeSantis cites about the 18 month old a
baby who was crawling on the floor of an
Airbnb and touched Fentanyl and ingested
fentanyl in some way and died as a
result of this I mean I don't know if
you guys saw the daycare the Bronx
daycare which was um this was a story I
think basically last week where a
two-year-old in New York City died of uh
I guess ingesting fentanyl in the
daycare despite having passed all of its
City inspections was actually being used
as a drug front and so now the city is
going after the people who were running
the daycare and and running the drug
front as well
um but it's it's interesting right
because these stories capture people's
imaginations it's kind of a little bit
of a throwback to Milk Carton Kids and
we see this moral plan surrounding kids
kids and razor blades kids and Fentanyl
kids and you know whatever they might be
able to access and a I I need to like
sort of independently do my own research
and actually verify that this anecdote
exists because just because somebody
said it on a debate stage does not mean
it is actually grounded in fact and two
like but I think it's actually probably
better to bring the discussion closer to
reality where like yes maybe every once
in a while there's an anomalous absurd
absurdly terrifying story uh like the
Bronx daycare one or like this 18 month
old in this Airbnb but fundamentally we
don't really have a country where like
millions of children are ingesting
Fentanyl and dying each year like let's
be very clear about what the problem is
there is an opioid crisis but I think it
would actually be better to Focus the
conversation on the median opioid user
and addict and how to get them the
treatment that they need not these
outlier cases well but I mean the
problem I mean these these cases are not
the typical fentanyl problem but we're
you know we're having on the order of a
hundred thousand drug overdose tests and
you're in the country it's and it's
massively higher than it used to be and
it's you know it's a legitimately
extremely hard policy problem I think a
much harder policy problem than the
immigration issue which I think we know
what the trade-offs are and what the
solutions would be the I mean the reason
we ended up with this fennel problem is
as you described Zach is we went through
this period where the uh prescribing uh
guidelines for opioids were much too
lacks and this seems to have been
largely an honest mistake there was a
sense in medicine that basically you
know lots of people have chronic pain
and this was a safe way to treat chronic
pain and it was a huge mistake and it
created this large number of people with
opioid addictions and then you had that
progression in the market through heroin
and then fentanyl but I think you know
one less to take from that is if you
hadn't even if you had an even more
permissive legal opioid policy where it
was not just they were going to go back
to writing a lot more prescriptions but
that we were going to you know get rid
of prohibition and allow people to just
go out and buy Percocet if they wanted
you would still have a tremendous number
of addicts and overdose deaths and you
you wouldn't have two-year-olds
stumbling upon a block of fentanyl in
the back of a in the back of a daycare
because it would be a legal Market but
the legal Market would be a source of
enormous problems in the country and so
it's you know that it's not like
marijuana where you can just you know
look at the the costs and the benefits
and say you know prohibition was
ridiculous and we're better off with
with permitting this you know you end up
with enormous social costs regardless of
which policy you choose and I think
that's part of why you end up getting
this Fantastical like let's invade
Mexico because if there was a simpler
clearer thing to do about it that's what
they'd be proposing to do which is not
to say that I think Mexico thing is
going to work it's just people people
get into these Realms when they lack a
good answer
yeah I I agree that there's no uh
there's no perfect solution
um and that that opioids are certainly
uh much more damaging drug when abused
than something like cannabis
um the problem is that shift it you know
cracking down on the opioids after that
the over prescription happened then made
basically what it led to is a lot of
people turning to heroin and then once
that demand for heroin went up then oh
look it's she it's even more efficient
to just make this in a lab in China or
wherever and then sneak it over the
border and so I think that you know that
there could be a more sophisticated
conversation about trade-offs and
accepting that these that there are
going to be social ills but perhaps
there are less damaging uh interventions
than uh kind of the simplistic let's
just crack down on it and see see you
know what pops up next uh Liz I
interrupted regardless the type of
conversation that you guys are modeling
which acknowledges some externalities
and unintended consequences that arise
from different policies and Trace the
evolution of how we got into this mess
to me that's a much more interesting way
to do debate and so I really really wish
and I know this will never really happen
in U.S politics but I wish we could move
away from like 18 month old babies
stumbled across a little bit of Fentanyl
and died and it's like the super outlier
moral panicky type case and toward the
types of things that you guys are
talking about which I think are both
extremely valid ways of approaching this
I'm sorry but like if we actually want
serious policy making and serious people
in the white house we should have the
expectation that that's where the
conversation happens as opposed to
whatever [__] we saw on the stage
last night
Liz you wanted to talk about the
education segment where DeSantis and
Nikki Haley talk about school choice and
other AD reforms uh in South Carolina in
their respective states of South
Carolina and Florida let's roll that
clip
you say choice is the answer but
button won't be fully implemented until
2027.
parents can't wait for years for a fix
so what would you do right now well in
school choice isn't the only answer but
I'll tell you it's not out of a lack of
trying that we didn't try and get school
choice in South Carolina what I'll tell
you first of all is we have to
acknowledge the fact that 67 percent of
our eighth graders are not proficient in
reading or math over 80 percent of our
eighth graders aren't proficient in
history or Civics and recently they came
out and said our 12 and 13 year olds are
scoring at the lowest levels they've
been scoring in reading and math in
decades so the first thing we've got to
do is we've got to make sure we catch
our kids back up we have to make sure
they can read a child that can't read by
third grade is four times less likely to
graduate high school we need to do
reading remediation we need complete
transparency in the classroom no parent
should ever wonder what's being said or
taught to their child in the classroom
we need to make sure that we have school
choice so that there's competition we
need to move all the programs from the
federal government down to the States
and let States decide what education
looks like in their states and we need
to start building things in America
again let's put vocational classes back
in our high schools and let's get our
kids building the things that we know
that we can make when we start to focus
on that and really bring in that
parental involvement that's when we'll
start to see a difference but we've got
to get parents back included we've got
to quit spending time on this Dei and
CRT and instead focus on financial
literacy on digital literacy and on
making sure that our kids know what they
need to do to have the jobs of the Next
Generation here's the deal our country's
education system is in decline because
it's focused on indoctrination denying
parents rights Florida represents the
Revival of American Education we're
ranked number one in the nation in
education by U.S news and World Report
my wife and I we have a six five and
three year old this is personal to us we
didn't just talk about Universal school
choice we enacted Universal school
choice we didn't just talk about parents
Bill of Rights we enacted the parents
Bill of Rights we eliminated critical
race Theory and we now have America
American Civics in the constitution in
our schools in a really big way just
like President Reagan asked for and is
farewell addressed back in 1989 Florida
is showing how it's done we're standing
with parents and our kids are benefiting
what struck you about that Liz so I
think DeSantis is much more rhetorically
compelling there uh Haley's sort of
laundry listed uh to a degree that I
found quite obnoxious and annoying but
the substance of what she's saying is I
think so important this is really I mean
the time is absolutely ripe for
a move towards school choice there are
more people now than ever opting out of
the public school system we are seeing
this sort of revolution in terms of a
return to phonics based education for a
long time the literacy programs used in
most public schools in the country for
maybe the last 10 years 15 years have
not actually been preparing people to
read at grade level and so we're seeing
these huge issues all the statistics
that Nikki Healey cited are accurate
it's a huge problem and for Nikki Haley
to ground the issues with public schools
in those clear stats versus culture War
stuff at least to me I would much prefer
to have somebody like that in charge I
think that's so important it's actually
very focused on things that affect real
families we can argue all day about
whether or not Maya kobabe's genderqueer
is in school libraries or not but
fundamentally whether or not children
are literate to me that's one of the
most fundamental jobs of public schools
and I appreciate Nikki Haley bringing
the conversation there it does bother me
though that in this moment when from the
Republican perspective teachers unions
exercised so much influence over the
course of the pandemic and kept school
Shut for so long they elbowed their way
to the front of the vaccination lines
claiming that that would allow schools
to be opened in person sooner and then
kind of went back on their words we had
the hysterics and the melodramatics of
them you know doing all those protests I
think in Chicago and La where they
brought coffins to marches saying
basically if you put us back in the
classroom if you reopen Public Schools
we the teachers will die on mass as a
result of this we saw horrible
horrifying behavior from teachers unions
over the course of the pandemic so you
would think that this election would be
where people like Rhonda Santos and
people like Nikki Haley can really make
a forceful pitch and say look like the
school library stuff is crazy like
leftists are being a little bananas
there but really more than anything
literacy is an issue teachers unions
behaved abysmally kovid was Grace the
degree to which schools were kept shut
for so long you would think they would
be able to convert all of that into a
really Salient compelling pitch for
school choice and I'm kind of frustrated
by the fact that like DeSantis substance
isn't there but Nikki Haley's form isn't
there
I find something odd about this
conversation in in that you know they're
talking about returning power to the
states and then further devolving the
power from the states by having
Universal school choice but then they're
also offering all of this prescriptive
guidance about how education should work
and you know obviously a president can
have influence and if you have a regime
like that there are things that the
president can do that that might
influence the way that schools educate
and what's in curricula and how phonics
is taught and that sort of thing but
ultimately if you if you believe this
stuff about having this much more
decentralized education system with
power the federal government plays a
smaller role State local governments
effectively play a smaller role because
you're going to have school choice and
vouchers and parents deciding where
they're going to send their money then
you kind of don't get to make the
decisions about you know is there going
to be CRT in the curriculum
um you know why how are they going to
teach reading all those sorts of things
and sort of the I think there's a
tension there it's like do we do we have
a bunch of top-down ideas about how
education needs to work differently or
are we deciding that we're not going to
impose those sorts of ideas and we'll
just let parents do whatever they want
yep I agree that the tension is there
and you even hear it in desantis's
answer where he's talking about
Universal school choice being
implemented in Florida which I think is
a great thing which I'm benefiting from
but at the same time he's talking about
uh you know implementing a certain
Civics curriculum that Ronald Reagan
would have loved and that that is the
tension that is unfortunately at the
center of a lot of this Ed policy at the
moment I mean Glenn yunkin in Virginia
basically ran uh successfully against
all of the you know the the excesses or
like the drag queen Story Hour stuff and
that uh is fine if you're uh and I mean
the thing is it actually it worked it
activated a lot of parents who were
worried about what their kids are
getting exposed to in school but then
you've got who I people who I see as Bad
actors uh the Chris ruffos of the world
world who they are not really interested
in kind of the pluralistic vision of
school choice that I favor they're
interested in just a takeover and sort
of if you know transmitting their values
through a state run system uh so I think
that's something we have to be uh you
know those of us who on this stream and
who are listening who are Advocates of
that need to be a little bit on guard
against in in this whole conversation I
mean the through line with so much of
this is the policies they are actually
advocating for
cannot really be put into effect the way
that they seem to claim I'm sorry but
like we're talking about like declaring
war with Mexico we're talking about
doing all of this crazy top-down
engineering of the public school system
despite the fact that so much of that is
state-based it's totally untethered from
reality
I I just quickly note I I'm I I'm
skeptical of the narrative that Glenn
young can won on education certainly he
ran on education and he won but they had
a Governor's election in New Jersey on
the same day where the Republican
candidate over performed by even more
New Jersey is a blue state so the
Republican narrowly lost and then the
swing toward Junkin was was pretty
uniform across Urban Suburban rural
areas in Virginia so it's not like it
was a specific thing in these you know
Loudoun County Fairfax County this
handful of suburban districts where
there were these curriculum disputes I
think that you know it was a rough
environment for Democrats in 2021
politically for a number of reasons and
I think young can won there I don't I
don't I don't really think that it was
specifically about the education issue
well so what do you make of that gaffe
then I mean we saw big polling upticks
right after I guess that Gap happened
very close to the election but like what
are other
explanations that you pause it I I think
you know I I think there was a lot of
dissatisfaction with the fact that the
the reopening from covid had not gone as
it was supposed to uh and we were you
know starting to have an inflation
problems we were having shortages I
think it's you know I think it's a lot
of the same issues look I don't I I
don't think it was great that Terry
McAuliffe went on that debate stage and
said that he didn't what I forget what
the exact quote was but you know that
education shouldn't be up to parents or
whatever it was
um but you know I just you know I I feel
like if it was if it was really about
these these School Board fights I would
have thought you would have seen a
greater swing in the parts of the state
where the school board fights were
really Salient which was basically the
suburbs but okay so I I think that
that's well taken and that's an
interesting Theory but the thing that
I'm curious about is like just because
it was playing out in Loudoun County or
what have you doesn't mean that coal
country Virginians weren't also looking
at that and being like yeah hell yeah
like go go go get him I guess I mean I
don't like I guess it depends how
rational voters are I mean most of those
voters are in a county where there's a
school board that's not going to go in
for any of this fatter stuff anyway but
so it's not like they need the governor
to stop their school board from doing
something I mean it's probably like my
counter to that would just be like just
because it's unlikely to happen to them
doesn't mean appellation voters aren't
riled up by that that's fair yeah yeah
no I like your pushback on that
hypothesis so that frankly makes me want
to dig in a little bit deeper to the
polling data and sort of like do a
little bit of a retrospective there
so the first clip that I wanted to talk
about here was this scuffle over Ukraine
where you've got DeSantis and ramaswamy
on one side uh and also by the way more
or less uh they're on they're taking the
Trump position on this issue uh and then
everyone else on another let's play that
today Republican party is at odds over
Aid to Ukraine the price tag so far is
76 billion dollars
but is it in our best interest to
degrade Russia's military for less than
five percent of what we pay annually on
defense especially when there are no U.S
soldiers in the fight it's in our
interest to end this war and that's what
I will do as President we are not going
to have a blank check we will not have
U.S troops and we're going to make the
Europeans do what they need to do but
they've sent money to pay bureaucrats
pensions and salaries and funding small
businesses Halfway Around the World
meanwhile our own country is being
invaded we don't even have control of
our own territory we have got to defend
the American people before we even worry
about all these other things I will say
let's let's debate the fact that our
national vital interests is in degrading
the Russian military by degrading the
Russian military we actually keep our
homeland safer we keep our troops at
home and we all understand Article 5 of
NATO
I thought you said something about
waiting until you return to talk so well
hello so at the end of the day I'm going
to finish my I'll be happy to do it and
I'll respond I'll look forward to this
one right now um so at the end of the
day when you think about the fact if you
want to keep American troops at home
attack on NATO territory would bring us
and our troops in we have to level with
the American people on this issue the
reality is just because just
does not mean that Ukraine is
this is a country that has banned 11
opposition parties
the hurling person themselves isn't
helping China is the Real Enemy and
we're driving Russia further into
China's arms we need a reasonable peace
plan to end this especially if this is a
country whose president just last week
Ukraine that's a green light to China to
take Taiwan
okay so what I appreciate about this is
that this is the only the
it it represents I think possibly the
one of the most important kind of
political realignments in the past 10
years and the fact that this is the only
place that that debate is really
happening I think is interesting and
noteworthy I mean I think most of the
Democrats seem uh you know on the same
page on this the there's a majority of
the Republicans on this that stage also
are but then you've got this Vivek
DeSantis Trump
group that is skeptical of kind of what
what they characterize as a blank check
for Ukraine and
you know we're all sympathetic to the
ukrainians but we do have to take
account of the fact that the U.S is the
biggest uh funder of Ukraine both in
terms well combining uh combined
military and Financial Funding we you
know dwarf the next in line which would
be the EU and as such we play a huge
role in how this all unfolds like we
could be the the moderator set up there
kind of implied that you know it's just
a fraction of the US's military budget
which is true but I think the bigger
point is that because we are providing
so much we have a big say in how much
pressure is put on people to come to the
negotiating table or you know how long
this continues on we've got you know
estimates of half a million
military casual facilities on both sides
combined on both sides uh 24 000
civilian casualties so there's a high
price being paid here obviously
um and I think that it's an important
conversation I think that it shouldn't
just go unexamined uh the second thing I
just want to say about it is that why I
don't like
is how then there's always a pivot to
the new enemy which is like okay we
can't
keep writing a blank check to Ukraine
because we need to send troops to Mexico
or we need to amp up our pressure on
China I think that's still that that's
that's an ongoing problem uh with the
GOP and that that and our our politics
in general that there always has to be a
real clearly defined enemy um to look
tough going up against
I think there's an interesting contrast
here between DeSantis and ramaswami
because I think Rhonda Santos has been
intentionally actually pretty vague on
this and you know the the tone in which
he talks about this is a tone that
appeals to people who think that the US
has been too involved in this but really
you know when he says you know no black
check nobody is in favor of a black
check
um that can mean anything that doesn't
that doesn't mean that you're not going
to send any more support it's an
indication of some sort of skepticism
but you know the their P they're
Republicans who have been criticizing
Joe Biden for not doing enough and not
sending enough Munitions and there have
been weapon systems that Ukraine has
sought that certain people in Congress
would like him to send that Biden has
has blocked sending so you know it's the
Joe Biden is already in a position of
doing some but not all of the things
that the Ukraine Hawks would like done
and I think that Rhonda Santos is
leaving that option open
um whereas ramaswamy has this sort of
cockamami idea that you can come in and
impose a settlement
um and that one of the terms of that
settlement is that you require fire
Russia to break its alliance with China
which is both I think something that
Russia would be unlikely to overly agree
to and even if they did you wouldn't
have a good mechanism for enforcing that
you can't just like turn all of
geopolitics on one meeting like that
it's this very it's this very amateurish
idea that he has of how foreign policy
works and I think it you know it it
glosses over the fact that this debate
happens as though it's like the US
government decides what the nature of
this war is going to be but it's not
just that Ukraine is a sovereign country
um that already is not doing certain
things we'd like them to do but there's
also Europe is here and you know I think
I think almost everyone agrees with Ron
DeSantis that we would like the European
countries to be stepping up their
commitments and to some extent they've
already been doing that they've been
increasing their defense budgets and I
think that's been a healthy shift toward
Europe taking on more the responsibility
for its own defense but I think you know
the idea that you're gonna give you part
of Ukraine to Russia and get a pinky
swear from Putin that he's not going to
do any more invasions and that he'll
break his alliance with the Chinese now
not only will you not get that from
Russia that won't be acceptable either
to Ukraine or to Europe and therefore it
won't happen the Russians can't make
that deal if the if the EU countries are
still backing Ukraine in the in this
fight which which they would be
um so I think that you know what he's
proposing is very unrealistic and I also
you know I sort of suspect that whoever
the president is policy toward Ukraine
is going to change less than people are
expecting that it might because you know
because we are not the sole author here
the corollary to what you're saying of
course is the fact that it affects a
Taiwan plan is also not so brilliant
um I forget the specifics in part
because they're so um mind-bendingly
stupid uh but it's that we'll tell China
they're not allowed to invade Taiwan
until 2028 by which time we'll be able
to make our own uh semiconductors yeah
it's related to like semiconductor
Independence and it's like basically you
know going from the Strategic ambiguity
uh approach now to like and I also love
that he's like publicizing this entire
strategy via Twitter and so it's not
like China like he's like oh we'll pull
the wool over their eyes by advertising
like by broadcasting this uh all over
like what it's just this completely it's
almost like he like thinks he's like
playing a board game like he thinks he's
playing risk with people in his college
dorm or something utterly brain dead
like that and it's just it's I think
it's so clear that he's not interested
in having a very serious grounded in
reality conversation about this which is
a especially like obnoxious given the
fact that so much of Congress right now
is occupied by this question of what to
do about Ukraine Aid uh and there's
these interesting sort of far-right-ish
dissenters in the house that are
actually really making a huge stink
about this so you would think that this
would be a good jumping off point for
some of these people on stage to be able
to more cogently reasonably discuss
um whether or not that's a good strategy
what they would do as the executive and
instead vivec is just like oh yeah we'll
just like disallow China from doing
certain things until 2028 it's like what
planet are you living in
let's go to the next clip which is about
for Vic ramaswamy joining Tick-Tock
after the influencer turned MMA fighter
Jake Paul apparently talked him into it
let's roll that Tick Tock is banned on
government government issued devices
because of its ties to the Chinese
government yeah you joined Tick Tock
after dinner with boxer and influencer
Jake Paul
should the commander-in-chief be so
easily persuaded by an influencer so the
answer is I have a radical
applicant party we need to
elections and
actions is reaching the next generation
of Young Americans where they are so
when I get into office I've been very
clear kids under the age of social under
the age of 16 should not be using
addictive social media we're only going
to ever get to declaring independence
from China which I favor if we actually
win so while the Democrats are running
rampant reaching the next generation
three to one there's exactly one person
in the Republican party which talks a
big game about reaching young people and
that's me this is infuriating because
Tick Tock is one of the most dangerous
social media apps that we could have and
what you've got I honestly every time I
hear you I feel a little bit Dumber for
what you say because I can't believe
they hear me Tick-Tock situation what
they're doing is these 150 million
people are on Tick Tock that means they
can get your contacts they can get your
financial information they can get your
email and thank you let me just say text
messages
in China not America excuse now wanting
kids to go and get on the social media
that's dangerous for all of us you went
and you were in business with the
Chinese that gave Hunter Biden five
million dollars we can't trust you we
don't trust you
have 15 seconds
15 seconds Mr rameshwari thank you I
think we would be better served as a
Republican party if we're not sitting
here hurling personal insults and
actually have a legitimate debate about
policy
I you know obviously there's several
Dimensions to this policy debate and
some of them are stupider than others I
I just find it remarkable that you know
this has been identified as a problem by
both political parties for several years
at this point and there's been a lot of
fighting over it and this nonsense that
they tried to do in the Trump
Administration where they're gonna like
get a big deal for Oracle to do the
server provision for tick tock which
didn't seem to address any of the
problems but would make a whole bunch of
money for Oracle but basically you know
the the criticism here that I think is
the most valid is that you know free
speech and free markets not require you
to allow an authoritarian foreign
government to own and control a media
entity in the United States and in fact
we've already forced the Chinese to
discourage one social platform which was
Grindr uh which was acquired by a
chinese-controlled company a few years
ago and that was reviewed by the this
cypheus Committee in the treasury
Department and found that that was
National Security risk and they were
forced to sell the app back to a US
owner
um and that you know that that didn't
interfere with people's ability to
access grinder but it did ensure that
you know that we were protecting this
you know this platform that contained a
lot of information from Americans from
being controlled by a by a hostile for
an entity and I think you know I think
it is a real concern that you know the
tick tock algorithm which is a Black Box
gives the Chinese government which is
unelected a lot of ability to to
influence the way in which information
is received by Americans I don't think
we would have allowed the Soviets to do
that during the Cold War and so it seems
it feels to me like there's a there's a
relatively narrow policy area here where
the you know there's there's some talk
of whether you could use the existing
law that was used for grinder whether
you could use that on Tick Tock because
of some us-based entities that they've
already acquired saying that you know
Tick Tock is a formerly U.S company that
was acquired but even if it wasn't you
could have a new law and you could have
a solution where you don't take Tick
Tock away from anyone but you make sure
that it is not controlled by the Chinese
government which it seems to me like
that there shouldn't even be a
Libertarian objection to because we're
not here to protect the the association
rights of the Communist Chinese
government
like what in your view and in the stuff
that you have read what do you think the
harm caused by Tick Tock and tick tock's
access to Americans data is like do you
mind just like going into a little bit
of detail there because I so frequently
get frustrated by this conversation in
this debate because it's like this is
bad but people infrequently expand on
what specifically is bad about it so my
main concern is about the algorithm and
the and the content that people are
viewing more than it is about the user
data I you know I think that you know we
first of all we don't know the extent to
which that they're making algorithmic
choices that are promoting messages that
are favorable to the Chinese government
or suppressing messages that they don't
like but the other thing is that you
know if you when they control this
platform that like half of Americans are
using they can they can do that and flip
a switch in the future and it takes
years to do to rest control of it away
from them so I think it's you know it's
worth doing even if we haven't
identified something that they are doing
yet because especially if you know if we
got into a situation if there was a war
over Taiwan for example where the
tensions were even higher between the
U.S and China I don't think we'd want
them having that sort of power as for
user data I'm not that concerned about
them having you know large volumes of
data on lots of Ordinary People which is
probably a very little value to the
Chinese and there are supposed to be
certain privacy protections that are
that are created by the apple and the
Google App Stores I don't have a good
technological sense of how foolproof
that stuff is
um but you know you you certainly you
could have specific targets of Chinese
surveillance where it might be useful to
have access into some relatively small
number of people's phones and I think
that could be a concern but my my main
concern is about Tick Tock as a media
company rather than to talk as a company
that has user data
machine that can just easily be right
you know dispensing you know bad
information to people in the event of
like a Taiwan Invasion okay that makes
sense yeah let me say this it's a it's a
legitimate concern for sure
um it is important to be real precise
and like dig down into the details of
what it is the government would be
banning I mean the company that you know
there's a parent company that owns Tick
Tock that is based in China and also
runs a Chinese version of tick tock
which is much different there's a
separate company based in the US that
supposedly runs the U.S version and they
say there's a firewall it's unclear how
strong that firewall is I would want any
sort of ban on you know manipulation of
the public through this kind of
propaganda you're talking about to be
pretty well proven out uh and something
that we the public would be able to see
instead of what we tend to get which was
the law that was proposed to ban Tick
Tock in the first place I encourage uh
people to go watch this the stream we
did on this which was a sprawling law
that would like you know was throwing in
trying to regulate crypto and Bitcoin
and like all uh telecommunications
infrastructure so that's kind of these
things just kind of get all jammed
together into this big power grab and
that's what I as a Libertarian get
really nervous about uh at any time we
start regulating uh social media even if
it's you know potentially a hostile
social media so yeah if you can prove
that there's some sort of
um you know propagandizing uh
intentional propagandizing happening
from a hostile foreign government that's
one thing but to Liz's point it it can't
be it can't be vague and it has to be
extremely targeted yeah I wouldn't want
the government regulating the algorithm
I mean first I don't really trust the
government to do that and then also like
even if the government did impose a
regulation I don't know how we would
ensure that that Tick Tock under Chinese
control was following the regulation
um what I want is is Ultimate Amer
American control and ownership over the
company
um and you know the I
the our Constitution and our culture of
free speech requires that you know that
people be able to do things like you
know decide what kind of information
they want to disseminate on their media
platform I don't really I don't want the
to take that out of the private sphere I
actually want to move it into the
private sphere so that it's not the
Chinese government so that it's some
private American entity doing that
I think it's also worth lingering on the
idea that the federal government is
going to regulate whether teenagers have
access to social media
um that seems like one of the crazier
ideas that is just routinely floated out
there on that stage I mean I think you
know Vivek uh he has it in for the young
people in general between that and his
uh proposal to you know make everyone
serve in some sort of civil service in
order to be able to vote until their age
uh you know a higher I think age 21 or
25. it was 25.
25 okay yeah so you know he's going on
uh Tick-Tock uh with uh Jake Paul but I
don't think he's courting the the youth
vote in fact he wants to outlot but
let's go to uh you know Liz you wanted
to talk about uh doug burgum because we
are burgam stands here uh and uh his
answer to a question about how to
actually shrink government let's roll
that one
big government keeps getting bigger
one-fifth of all new jobs this year have
been created by the government Governor
burgum you say you want to shrink the
size of government but it has been a
century since any president has done
that why would you be any different
well because we're doing we've doing
we've done it in North Dakota when I
took office We Shrunk the state budget
general fund by 27 percent and the first
four months I was office and we all the
trains still running on time why because
you had a business leader that was
actually there inside of every
government job there's 10 or 20 percent
of mind-numbing soul-sucking work that
even the state and federal employees
don't want to do and you can engineer
that work out of the job that would free
up right there at 20 of 2 million
civilian employees and by the way we've
got 10 million jobs open they'd have
plenty to do and they could be in
generating taxes instead of being paid
by taxes this is totally possible to do
it if you have somebody that understands
because having worked in technology for
30 years everything we had to do was to
be better faster and cheaper the next
day that's what we can do in government
that's what we're doing in North Dakota
all right
yeah so I I hate to be like that
technocratic [__] but what he is
talking about is totally reasonable and
it's kind of uh disturbing to me that
this type of sound bite isn't heard way
more often I'm sorry but there is just
an obscene amount of government waste
the fact that we are just pouring you
know in all kinds of States all over the
country and at the federal level we are
pouring so much money into various
projects I was just on a podcast earlier
this morning talking about California's
doomed rail infrastructure projects and
comparing that to brightline in Florida
which to be fair also I believe was
completed a little bit behind schedule
but it is stunning the amount of waste
we have at all levels of government and
I think it is absolutely important to
just kind of keep going back to that I'm
sorry but if you were asking to fund
more government programs or to fund them
to a higher degree the fundamental
question that I want to ask as a
taxpayer is well how much money have we
already poured into it and have we seen
the results that we expected and if not
why who is to blame where is the drug
worth inefficiency here I think it is
such a bummer I mean look Doug burgum
looks like a scarecrow he looks like if
Matthew McConaughey had some sort of
like weird accident
um like he is obviously not a super
charismatic guy he's not extremely
Charming I know he's not actually going
to get elected but my God what a bummer
that somebody like Doug burgum who was
actually on the stage talking sense
attempting to just elbow his way in
there to get a little bit of air time
for whatever reason people just don't
really give a [__] uh and that's a huge
bummer to me I think it says really
sorry it shows that uh we're in a very
sorry State politically the fact that he
sort of decides to just consistently
abstain from the culture warring and
focus a little bit more on the
importance of I mean he's the only one
bringing up uh energy policy I know
Chris Christie actually had decent
answers about like Ai and Tech stuff but
Doug burgum is just consistently
actually returning the conversation to
questions of government efficiency and
to thinking about how we should sort of
get out of the way of the private sector
to me that's what an executive ought to
be doing
I will pile on with some of the burgum
appreciation because this may be the
last time we see or hear from him but uh
one thing that I appreciate about uh his
approach is that he is the kind of old
school like actual Federalist type
Republican where he'll pull the
constitute the pocket Constitution out
and say yeah you know even though I'm
against abortion uh this is not
something that's authorized in here or I
think he did it again when we're talking
about the trans issues so I think the
Republican Party would do well to get
back to that sort that sort of uh
federalism going forward Josh any uh
bergam comments well well they're still
available I wasn't that impressed by by
this I mean I just found a little vague
I you know I'm sure that there are lots
of places where there's waste that you
can cut out but you know that it
involves doing specific things and often
the reason that you know that these
things haven't been fixed before is that
it's harder it's harder than it sounds
to to figure out oh like you know this
is this is the thing you need to get rid
of I mean you use the the bright light
example and I think that there are some
specific lessons to take there about
Braille I mean first of all it helps
that Florida is basically flat
um they did a diesel system and they're
not having to install catenary wire all
over the place where they're building
new rail line it basically goes through
the middle of nowhere runs down the
median of a highway in Orlando it's not
going all the way downtown it's going to
a stop basically in a swamp outside the
airport and there's downsides to that
you can't really walk to anything from
the station but it does save money on
land acquisition and engineering and so
they're you know there's there are
specific lessons that you can take out
of brightline which I think is an
impressive project but the problem is
that sort of tells you certain things
about how to build rail in certain
places and then you have to do that
hundreds and hundreds of times over with
other different areas of government and
sometimes it's going to work and
sometimes it's not going to work well
sure so I mean maybe the bright line
versus California rail example is a
subpar one but you could look at the
struggles that the IRS has had with
digitizing
uh their services and you could look at
I mean obviously there's the most recent
infusion of cash so it's it's not
reasonable to expect the IRS to have
perfectly you know reformed the way they
do things over the course of the last
year year and a half but I mean the IRS
has been basically wasting money and
really struggling
um to actually carry that out for the
better part of like what a decade and so
I think you could point to like a
federal agency that the executive would
have much more control over in terms of
appointing who is in charge of it and
you could say like has the IRS used
their money well over the last 15 years
because we just gave them a whole crap
ton more money and so I would at least
have a little bit of trepidation if if I
were president with attempting to figure
out how we are going to appropriately
audit their use of funds
and just to return to the brightline
example for a second Josh isn't the
fundamental difference that this bright
line is managed by a for-profit company
so they have more of an incentive to
make sure that they actually turn a
profit down the line and and that that
kind of relates to what burgum was
saying he's saying you know as a tech
executive I have some understanding of
the role that kind of you know
entrepreneurship and uh you know private
markets play and balancing those
properly with the state as opposed to
somewhere like California where you're
building a rail and you know
compromising with all these stakeholders
so that the rail diverts through this
one County Commissioner's uh District
that that it's just a completely
different mindset and perhaps that is
missing from our federal government the
moment yeah I mean I I think you know
the bright brightline obviously is
private and for-profit there are you
know government assistance aspects to
this with bonding and that sort of thing
but no I think it's been a very good
model and they're taking it out West to
build a rail line from Las Vegas to sort
of the Inland Empire
um I think there are you know there are
limited numbers of places where that's
going to work I mean look the the the
California rail thing is a complete
boondoggle and it's good money after bad
and they should shut it down even though
it's going to make people sad over there
um but I don't you know I I don't I
don't know that there would have been a
viable way to build a bright line type
project running from San Francisco to
Los Angeles just because of the the ways
in which the engineering would have been
very complicated and again you you could
have made choices like that you're you
know the I think you're referencing how
the line instead of running down the
median of I-5 through the middle of
nowhere through Central California it
runs through all the mid-sized cities in
the Central Valley and that adds
tremendous expense it doesn't add that
much ridership it's also curve up
through the desert because of an L.A
County supervisor's political influence
there left yeah a republican supervisor
would know yeah
um but uh the yeah so it's you know it's
the it's a set of political compromises
that that led to that outcome but I you
know the I the just the Mir all the all
the mountains you have to tunnel for
there I don't think you would have been
able to get a purely private project to
pencil in the way that it does with with
brightline not not it's it's a good
model but it's it's not going to work
for everything I I think it's worth
maybe not getting too caught up on the
Breitling example one thing I think
about with Doug bergum is that I mean he
I believe built a little bit of a
fortune for himself based off of selling
uh creating an accounting software
company and then he's been in the
software Venture Capital space uh since
then in addition to obviously being
governor of of North Dakota
um and I think the interesting thing to
me is just like well this is really
useful interesting executive experience
I could definitely see him bringing
um almost the venture capitalist mindset
to the table in terms of thinking about
like how do we invest in a whole bunch
of uh interesting or you know moonshot
projects not expecting the only of them
will come to fruition but attempting to
sort of you know leverage uh you know
where we're spending money and I would
like to see just broad Strokes more of
that type of mindset that type of skill
set in government I think the fact that
we are just so uh constantly fixated on
Career politicians on like the [__]
Gavin newsoms of the world versus the
Doug burgums is just such a it's it's
no surprise to me why we continue to be
in such a sad political place when
that's what we collectively prioritize
and value no I look I I agree with that
my sole objection maybe I was to fixate
it on this is that I you know I I'm just
skeptical of the idea that that then
leads to a 10 or 20 cut in in the
workforce I I just I've found that to be
a simplistic it's impossible at least
especially initially one thing that
would actually be good if they want to
be Tethered to reality not that I voters
really give a [__] about this but it's
like it's not like you do all these
things on day one and it's not like you
make all these massive Cuts just all at
once what happens typically is you do
things over the course of many years and
so I mean the day one is such a classic
political debate stage Trope but I'm
really sick of it just because it
strikes me as completely impossible I
guess the idea is to signal to voters I
prioritize this highly but fundamentally
you can't prioritize seven different
massive policy areas highly you need to
kind of figure out what you're about and
frankly trying to do a whole bunch of
things uh in a super speedway or on day
one probably leads to really really poor
implementation
um and I wish voters were a little bit
more sensitive to that
on this topic of cutting government
reducing the spending that my final clip
was one I picked because a there's a
direct call out of Donald Trump which
Harkens back to the beginning of our
discussion and B there's discussion of
the national debt which I've come to
view as an increasingly concerning topic
and it was at least brought up a few
times here
where's Joe Biden he's completely
missing an action from leadership and
you know who else is missing in action
Donald Trump is missing in action he
should be on this stage tonight he owes
it to you
to defend his record where they added
7.8 trillion to the debt that set the
stage for the inflation that we have we
don't get any answers because Joe Biden
hides in his basement and won't answer
as to why he's raising the debt the way
he's done and Donald Trump be hides
behind the walls of his golf clubs and
won't show up here to answer questions
like all the rest of us are up here to
answer he put seven trillion on the debt
he should be in this room to answer
those questions and I want to look at
that camera right now and tell you
Donald I know you're watching you can't
help yourself I know you're watching
okay and you're not here tonight not
because of polls and not because of your
indictments you're not here tonight
because you're afraid of being on the
stage and Defending Your record you're
ducking these things and let me tell you
what's going to happen you keep doing
that no one up here is going to call you
Donald Trump anymore we're going to call
you Donald Duck
he's so proud yeah let's just let's just
look at that for a second the
self-satisfaction it's you know that
line is like so lame and grown-inducing
and it has been in every debate clip
Roundup I have seen after the debate it
has achieved exactly what he intended
for it to achieve and I think you know I
think he knew that it was like a total
groaner and he also knew that like it
would be at the top of the hour in the
Montage on CNN every hour and it has
been
I give Chris Kristin credit for uh pure
entertainment value uh he's 10 out of 10
on both of these debates
um the you know that that that also uh
brought this moment which you uh pointed
you were tweeting about this morning
Josh uh that uh New York Times uh fact
check was prompted by this Christie's
statement that Joe Biden hides in his
basement uh this is false uh any
comments on oh my God
I just I hate fact checking I mean like
because because the the Temptation that
the fact Checkers always succumb to is
they go beyond like factual claims and
they talk about you know well like this
was analysis and was it good analysis or
did this lack important context and
things that are ultimately judgment
calls and I think you know like in in
sort of fairness New York Times they're
not so much correcting the literal
statement they're not being like he's
not in his basement what they're saying
is Well like they're like they're saying
Joe Biden doesn't go out and do stuff
but he does go out and do stuff and he
traveled to all these countries he's
like no like when you say Joe Biden is
hiding in his basement you mean he's not
out in public as much as he should be
and you mean that his that the White
House is trying to control his public
appearances in a way to minimize
spontaneity and minimize the number of
questions he's going to face
um because they're they're afraid of
what will happen if he goes off script
um and those are ultimately those are
not factual claims those are opinion an
opinion of how much the how many
interviews the President should give how
many events outside the White House he
should do there's no right or there's no
fact about that and so ultimately what
this from The New York Times basically
ultimately defending the idea that Biden
is out there enough
um which I think partly is a weird thing
to do as a media Outlet when you know
one of the key aspects of Biden's
strategy has been that he does very few
interviews many fewer interviews than
presidents before him have typically
done but you know it's it's not even so
much about whether the times is analysis
on on that is right or wrong it's that
they shouldn't be doing that analysis at
all it's a question for voters whether
they think that Joe Biden is out there
as much as he should be and that's you
know obvious honestly what Chris
Christie was arguing about there
yeah I mean the fact-checking industry
or complex seems to have taken a pretty
big hit in credibility over the past
several years do you think there's sort
of a path back for that whole framework
well today it's not clear to me what the
usefulness of it is to begin with I mean
I think it's you know people have been
driven nuts over the last eight years by
like people thinking things that are
wrong and you know some some of that is
you know like cancel culture and trying
to to restrict opinions but some of it
is literally about things that are wrong
that like you know there's you know
there's been a lot of prominent
conspiracy theorizing and a lot of you
know like nonsense claims about you know
Donald Trump really won the election
that sort of thing things that are
actually Incorrect and it drives a lot
of especially liberals crazy and it
drives a lot of reporters crazy and
they're not entirely wrong about it but
just sort of like grabbing people by the
shoulders and being like I'm going to
give you the real facts now is is not a
strategy that's working in part because
the sort of people who are bothering to
read the New York Times live stream
dream about the debate are not even the
audience that they they really need to
reach if they're trying to disabuse
people of false factual Notions so I
would if I had a fact check arm at my
news Outlet I would I would just shut it
down if you know the most of what
appears in fact checks is stuff that can
just appear in a news story format and
sometimes even when you have a fact
check that's really not about facts it's
you know it's an analysis about what the
context for this
ought to have been you could repackage
that as an article and often it would be
an informative interesting article and
you just lose the distracting frame
where you're claiming to be you know
setting straight some some fact
and to return to the the policy
substance of that earlier clip you know
I appreciate that there was some mention
of the climbing debt uh because I I
think it could become a very serious
problem and I am not that being said I'm
not optimistic that anyone on that stage
is pro-offering any solutions to get it
under control they're kind of just
mentioning the number and then not
mentioning any sort of path to reducing
that either through increased revenue or
you know cutting the programs that are
responsible for you know or you know our
our biggest uh programs are entitlements
that's like off the table for anyone on
that stage to mention at this point it
seems DeSantis used to mention it when
he was in Congress and but he's gotten
hammered by Trump for those comments and
now nobody brings it up so
I'm glad it's a topic of conversation
based on the policies not offered and
also past performance of Republicans in
office I can't say I'm optimistic that
any of them kind of have what it takes
to like push forward a real agenda of
bringing that under control
Nikki Haley has talked some about
entitlements needing to be on the table
um I mean it's very unpopular that's why
they don't like to do it I mean we also
we've just gone through 30 years of
persistently low interest rates and
situations where the there's usually
slack in the labor market in the economy
and so the the economic damage that
comes from government deficits in
certain economic situations has not
really applied very much through that
period it has been more or less true
that the government can borrow and spend
money without causing inflation without
crowding out private sector activity
that's over that ended with the the
pandemic and the economic whipsaw of the
pandemic
um and it's just you know the I mean the
last the last time we had real deficit
reduction politics was in the early 90s
there was a deficit reduction package in
1990 there was one in 1993 and then and
then there was one in sort of 2011-12
that I think wasn't wasn't actually good
for the economy at that time because we
were in that slack period but the last
time where you know it was really like
mortgage rates are too high and
politicians need to talk about how we
can change fiscal policy to take
pressure off interest rates so it's
cheaper for people to buy a house the
last time we had that was 30 years ago
and just almost no one who was in
politics then is still in politics and
voters aren't used to dealing with those
trade-offs I mean I think you know I
don't think we're going to have a really
serious deficit reduction effort until
we have some significant period of
economic pain driven by those deficits
which you know we'll need we'll need
some time with elevated interest rates
um and with you know that which are
which will limit business investment
um because it's you know it's too
expensive to expand your business
because interest rates are high you need
that to be a reality for people before
it becomes worthwhile for politicians
and for voters to say okay what pain am
I willing to bear in order to bring
about this economy in which will be
easier to invest and grow and I just
those conversations are never easy and
they're especially hard when you haven't
really had to have them for a few
decades will people see that causation
I mean if you if you go back and look at
the 1992 presidential debates they they
talk explicitly about it they talk about
like you know the like mortgage rates
are high because the deficit is big I
mean I don't know but do you think right
now that will happen again okay well I
right now no but I think that's a
conversation I mean over the next time
in the next few years you know say say
our you know country's credit rating
um you know goes down and say people
sort of this begins to be an actual
reality that Congress has to reckon with
you know two years from now or four
years from now when we're doing all of
this crap all over again do you think
that this will be something where we cut
through the culture war and this is what
we focus on or not so much maybe I mean
you know a lot of the Trump tax cuts are
going to expire at the end of 2025 and
that you know the Congress will have to
pass some new law or otherwise tax code
will be a real mess after that so that
sort of creates a lever where you're
gonna have to have some kind of fiscal
deal there and if control is split then
it'll have to be a bipartisan fiscal
deal
um but I mean the other problem here is
that we've also got through 30 years in
of bipartisan consensus that you should
never raise taxes on anyone who makes
less than like a quarter million dollars
a year
um and so that makes it very difficult
to draw up a balanced deficit reduction
package I mean Democrats are very big on
the idea that you you raise taxes on
corporations and rich people and you can
raise a substantial amount of money from
doing that but so not not quite as
substantial as a lot of Democrats seem
to think especially if they want to
expand the government and not just just
reduce the budget deficit
um and Republicans you know that have
ever since 1990 1990 was the last time
you had a broad-based tax increase that
got significant Republican votes that
was when George Bush Senior broke his no
new taxes pledge and that sort of was
the birth of Grover norquist's uh pledge
against raising taxes and I think
there's basically no way now to get
substantial Republican votes for a
revenue raising package so you'd have to
they'd have to have a plan that's all
spending cuts but they I mean they
weren't even saying that they want to
repeal Obamacare which used to be an
Applause line within the party at the at
this debate let alone you know
significant Cuts in in defense spending
or Medicare or Social Security and then
now we've just talked about most of the
budget so I think that uh you know the
we're very far from the realistic stage
of talking about what a what a what a
budget actually looks like that reduces
the deficit and I think it's also
telling that when Democrats had full
control and passed the so-called
inflation reduction act which was
supposed to be a deficit reduction bill
first of all it's not even clear that it
reduces the deficit at all because the
tax credits for green uh investment look
like they're gonna be more expensive
than expected but even if it's a lot
more expensive too not just a little
yeah yeah but you know even if it came
in where it was supposed to be it was
basically like they had a bunch of new
revenue and they spent what five sixths
of it on new spending and only six of it
went to deficit production like that was
just like the the if if to the extent
Democrats are already Limited in what
kind of taxes they're willing to raise
and then if they do that they want to
take most of the money and spend it not
reduce the deficit and that's you know
the neither of these conversations is
anywhere close to where you would need
to be if you were trying to actually
have real effects on economic conditions
by shrinking the deficit I feel pretty
pessimistic about people's ability to
see the connections here here
specifically I don't know whether it's
fair for me to extrapolate to the degree
that I am but thinking about the
relationship between covid stimulus
checks and the inflation that we're
currently dealing with the fact that
Sony people don't seem to grok the
connection which is not to say that
inflation is entirely attributable to
that but certainly we can all agree that
that was you know a substantial part of
it
um the fact that people don't quite grok
that relationship does not make me feel
super optimistic about their ability to
understand that going forward but you
know I am happy to stand corrected
and politics yeah I do fear that uh Josh
is 100 correct that it's only once it
hits a sort of I don't know crisis point
or at least people are really feeling it
that there's going to be any change I
mean you know you mentioned that there
was this decade or so that of where it
seemed that deficits didn't matter at
all because interest rates more than
more than a decade more than two decades
yeah yes I mean and during that time
there were people who were still saying
like we shouldn't let this get so out of
control because then if the interest
rates ever go up then we're not going to
have you know the kind of like dry
powder and that that was ignored uh so
you know any sort of like prevention or
preemptive measures to deal with this
stuff rarely seems to uh come to
fruition and you know the GOP now is
barreling towards a trump renomination
then Trump certainly seems like he has
zero interest in this I mean he loves
datch both government and personal
um and it does not seem to be you know
part of his his calculus whatsoever so I
don't see how it's going to be addressed
yeah
had a smart piece on this a couple of
months ago about how people aren't
really thinking enough about what a
trump Economic Policy would look like in
a second term that if he sort of reruns
his first term Playbook where it's like
cut taxes and give people whatever they
want and and you know run bigger
deficits and you know I love debt like
that that worked okay in the economic
conditions that prevailed then it wasn't
it wasn't inflationary I mean I'm
talking about the pre-covet period
um you know the the economy did grow a
little bit faster through that period
unemployment was low it basically worked
fine if you do that now if you come in
and say in in these economic conditions
I'm going to do what is really another
stimulus if you do another on finance
tax cut and then if you do what he did
with the Federal Reserve and lean on
them and say stop raising rates I want
you you to cut rights if he has success
with that or if he puts people on the
Federal Reserve board who will do what
he says on that you could have a really
big spike in inflation because of that
you know if it's you know if he just you
know decides that what he's going to do
is effectively send out more checks and
cut rates then people the the you know
excessive demand is going to get even
more excessive and you could see even
higher inflation than we saw in in 2022
um I don't think people have really
thought about that possibility and you
know the bizarre political effects would
have but I think that's I think that's
one real economic risk of a second Trump
presidency yeah for sure and you know
between that kind of brings me to the
final question here which is between
these offerings from the GOP bench and
indicted ex-president destroying them in
the polls uh an incumbents experiencing
obvious cognitive decline and then you
know Gavin Newsom kind of weirdly
lurking in the shadows
what is missing from the 2020 for
presidential race for you or maybe
another way to put it is
what where would you like to see this go
you know look I'll start with you yeah
I'm sure I have a much more positive
view on Joe Biden than the two of you do
you know I sort of give this presidency
a BB Plus
um you know the I so I'll be voting to
to re-elect him I you know I don't the
he's he's old he's obviously old when
people say cognitive decline I think
sometimes they're implying that he has
dementia or Alzheimer's which I don't
think is the case
um but you know I would have I would
rather have Joe Biden 10 years younger
as president than Joe Biden right now I
don't deny that his age you don't you
don't think he has uh dementia no no I
don't I think that you know I think he's
aging in in a normal manner but not in
like a you know like a clinically
diagnosable manner you know and a lot of
them that's funny here's a little bit
like what do you make of his sort of
inability to remember like what he's
talking about and whether or not he's
repeated a story two minutes ago I mean
I to some extent I think Joe Biden has
been like that for a lot of his
political career I mean he was never
known as a precise speaker
um so I you know I don't the I think you
know the even even though he is out
there publicly less than a lot of other
presidents are he still talks on camera
a lot and you can pick moments out of it
that create certain appearances but I
think you know the by I think it's clear
that he is running a white house that is
you know you may you might not like what
it's doing but it's broadly effective in
doing what is with in doing what it is
setting out to do uh politically so
you're not sitting there waiting for
Gavin Newsom to swoop in from the wings
that's just an excuse for you to talk
about your uh recent article about Gavin
Newsom like why is he not the Savior uh
in the situation well look I mean
Gavin's obviously going to run in 2028
and you know I'm sure he wakes up every
morning hoping that Joe Biden has died
so that he can go out there and run for
president and you know like more than
half of getting elected president does
good timing he's far from the only
person who's hoping that somebody in his
way will Keel over dead so that he can
go and become president they're all like
this but uh no I mean the the The Joe
Biden will be the Democratic nominee for
for president in in 2024.
um the thing about Gavin is that he he
does nothing to bring swing voters into
the Democratic party he's basically like
it's an engineered in the lab to make
MSNBC viewers happy and his big you know
his big attention grabbing initiative is
this proposal to create a constitutional
amendment to further restrict gun rights
which is never going to happen and if
Democrats campaign on it they will lose
elections because this is an issue where
salience really goes against them and
you know they they need to try to like
do less that makes people think that
they're going to try to take away their
guns but what it does do is it helps
Gavin Newsom build a big email list of
Grassroots Democratic donors who can
raise money from and who we can blast
emails out to if and when he eventually
runs for president and so it's it's a
really selfish thing he's doing
something that's harmful to the
Democratic party and helpful to him and
and I don't care for it and you know I I
wrote this you know the the this Gavin
Newsom is gross and embarrassing piece
and I you know I I actually I think
people don't fixate enough on the
personal behavior of politicians I think
that you know like you mean dating the
19 year old um
when he was 39 and mayor and he he had
an affair with his campaign manager's
wife he was married to Kimberly
Guilfoyle I mean it's like if I don't
want it disqualifying right if you look
at Behavior like if there was someone in
your life personally who was behaving
like this you would you would look
negatively upon it and I think it makes
sense to apply those sorts of Standards
to to political figures as well to look
at someone who looks like they conduct
themselves in an honorable manner from
day to day and I just I don't get that
vibe from him and I said like he sort of
has Bill Clinton Vibes for me except
that Bill Clinton was is Charming and
Gavin doesn't have that so I just I I
think he's I think he's totally wrong I
think California is a solid Blue State
being from California it adds nothing
politically for the party it's you know
this is also a Kamala Harris problem
um so I you know I feel a lot better
about some of the midwestern governors
in the party Gretchen Whitmer Josh
Shapiro I mean Pennsylvania's not
technically in the midwest but you know
the Rust Belt
um I think you know just who have a
broader appeal and have more experience
appealing to swing voters because
they've had to get themselves elected in
swing States
um and I think that's a better asset if
you're seeking the presidency so that's
where I would you know like to see us go
after Joe Biden I think like everybody
else I think Kamala Harris is kind of a
joke
um but you know in 2024 it's going to be
a question of you know four more years
of Biden and yes he will be he'll be a
really old president Conrad Adenauer was
the chancellor of West Germany until he
was 87. so it's been done before
Liz what are your what's the best you
can hope for out of 2024 here I would
really like a Peter Meyer type person
but who's like more of a straight
shooter I was reflecting as Chris
Christie was talking and I found myself
oddly Enchanted by him mostly I think
because I want to be like winter is
approaching and I really want to like
hang out in a dive bar and throw back
some like pickleback shots and Crush
some beers with like a Chris Christie
type straight shooter you know eat a
slice of pizza that type of thing I kind
of like that demeanor
um I would like to marry that whole vibe
with some pragmatism and actual
experience and I find Peter Meyer who um
was I guess Michigan's third
Congressional District representative
for um a bit uh to just be so
tantalizing I think it's really
wonderful I think efficacy should
actually be prioritized and I think
being honest with people
um I really really dislike the
pompousness of people like Vivek
ramaswamy and I think we even saw this a
little bit with uh Andrew Yang so does
some degree I want I want pragmatism and
I want honesty and I feel like there's
not really anybody who represents that
on stage right now a lot of Chris
Christie's policies I don't actually
like I think Nikki Haley arguably has
some of the qualities that I'm looking
for except that she is a war hawk to far
to create a degree uh that I'm
comfortable with and so I don't think
that she is actually a good
representative of the types of things
that I want to see done I feel now more
than ever uh incredibly politically
homeless and really frustrated by the
fact that
you know I there are so many people who
identify as independent but voters out
there who feel almost like what you're
talking about Josh I understand that you
know at the very beginning you opened
this up by saying that you think
political parties are important but you
were talking about how you used to be uh
sort of Republican leaning and now
you're more democrat-leaning but you're
frustrated by components of both parties
and I think that's such a common
sentiment I know so many people in New
York who are used to be pretty hardcore
Democrats and now very much feel like
the left has gotten co-opted by
silliness uh a lot of the PC stuff has
really driven them away and there's
there's this like it's a Trope at this
point the left left me
um but I would really like to see a
candidate that appeals to so many of
these people who feel as though their
parties whether Republican or Democrat
kind of abandoned them
um and it's kind of stunning to me that
we have so many candidates that feel not
like full carbon copies of each other
but a little too close for comfort and
for whatever reason we're not actually
focused on people being honest and
people being effective
for me you know the things I want out of
a president at this point is it's pretty
the bar's been way lowered I there's no
way I could limbo under it it's mostly a
list of don't do this thing like don't
end the world by blundering us into an
unnecessary devastating War don't wreck
the economy parts of that involve
actually addressing the debts at some
points don't wreck our civil society by
flouting the Constitutional limits
imposed on you or using rhetoric that's
designed to make Americans hate each
other
and
stay the hell out of my life as much as
possible and devolve power to the lowest
degree that you are able to I don't
think anyone on that stage hits all four
of those bullet points but uh there
might be people who are improvements to
some degree or another on both Trump and
Biden across multiple of those
Dimensions I hope you know to return
this to the the theme we touched on in
the beginning of this conversation that
the field gets a whittled and that
there's a bit more seriousness about
uh kind of coping with the situation
that the GOP finds itself at this moment
with Trump you know polling over 50
percent uh but not going to hold my
breath for it I I want to thank
um Josh Barrow for joining us today
thanks for having me Liz yeah and thanks
for everyone who tuned in and listened
we will be back next Thursday 1 p.m we
will see you there